hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday night Y and it's time for our
little movie review thing before we get
into that though is okay is everything
correct yeah no no not all is of course
it's not I look up and I said the fan
isn't on hold on well the fan hasn't
been on the last few times burn up
I'mma burn up well because earlier today
it was kind of cold in here so I don't
usually turn the fan on I only turn the
fan on like after I get out of the
shower it goes there it goes what are
you doing it took a
while there it's fine I think you just
pushed the wrong button that's probably
why I pushed every button there twice
and on the third time it's the one it's
the one on the left it's the one that I
don't know what the [__] the other the
other one does probably nothing uh but
yeah so this is acceptable yeah M before
we get into talking about the movie um I
would like to extend a like very sincere
thank you to one of our listeners Rachel
who gave us an extremely generous super
thanks on the Richard Simmons show
that's right gave us a $100 on the
Richard on the on the Richard we
couldn't believe it like Tom like I woke
up in the middle cuz I fell asleep while
we were watching a movie last night and
I yeah and I didn't see it and he's like
I think somebody just gave us a $100 on
one of the videos I'm like what and I
was like so tired so like I went in
there and looked at him I'm like holy
[__] he's like Maybe not maybe I didn't
see right so but I went in there and
looked on and absolutely someone did so
thank you very much ra Rachel because
that was like I was like wow I hope they
didn't like mistakenly cuz remember I I
remember that happened to Dan Bell one
time like cuz he always does live
streams on Saturday night and somebody
accidentally sent him $500 when they
went to send him $5 and they were
freaking out yeah and he was like trying
to figure out how to like give it back
to them and like reverse it and stuff
but yeah it was just like he he had to
get paid and then he sent it back to him
yeah yeah yeah yeah because yeah you
don't get like Google ads sense it's all
uh put into Google AdSense like with the
ad revenue and everything like that and
you just get it on the 21st so you have
to like we I saw that [__] I said I said
man that that
must that must have been him man maybe
that was actually Richard Simmons yeah
that must been Richard Simmons watch if
it was yeah hey man what's up yeah well
like I said I think I think we you know
cuz I just always thought like I said
the more that I like read about him and
stuff I'm like wow he just seems like a
really nice man you know what I mean so
um that's a good reminder if you're
listening to the show recorded
don't forget to give us a super thanks
if you can't ever make it to the live
shows give us Super Chat yeah just
saying but yeah I was just I was I was
flabbergasted I thought they made a
mistake or something that is very very
generous of you so thank you very much
for that so we don't usually do double
Fe well I guess we did do a double
feature because we didn't Hammer the
other day this is a double feature but
the two movies don't have [__] all to do
with each other we just decided to do
these just because we kind of watched
them like in quick succession and I kind
of wanted to talk about them both we
actually over this weekend we got into
we watched the whole um reanimator
Trilogy again yeah which but we've
already like we've already um reviewed
all of those so we don't we're going to
talk about those but yeah we just kind
of got into like watching those again
just all three of them cuz they have all
three of them on uh tub actually yeah we
also wanted to rewatch
Necronomicon but uh nobody's got it
anywhere got it there's something wrong
with the licensing for that it's got to
be like you know the one with Jeffrey
Colmes in it yeah
another weird thing is that when we were
watching movies last night and we didn't
review this one cuz I actually fell
asleep after we watched uh slave girls
from beyond Infinity the movie that came
on after that which what was that called
The Phantom Empire Phantom Empire yeah
happened to also have Jeffrey combes in
it yeah and I was like what the [__]
does somebody like know why it was just
really weird yeah it was and it was
right after reanimator yeah I think it
was like 87 or 88 or something like that
yeah it was just like it cuz he looked
like real young still yeah and he said
he was from m University which I said
man he's writing his own [__] he's
writing his own we're going to have to
finish we're going to have to finish
that I I fell asleep at the end I good
it was funny did you watch the whole
thing no oh okay it also had Ross Hagen
in it who if you are an MST fan was in
the side hackers except he's much older
in this one but I did like recognize
some of the people in it yeah so okay so
the first one I want to talk about is
alone in the dark now there's a lot of
movies called that I think probably the
best known one is the one didn't like
[__] who's that crazy German that
makes those terrible movies based on
video games U Bowl yeah he I think he
made one people to fight yeah yeah yeah
the guy that like wants to beat people
up for saying bad he probably wants to
beat me up now but it's just like I'm
Just a Girl U don't like you know what I
mean although he's probably an old man I
can maybe take him but um I don't think
he's ever serious about it anyway I
don't know yeah well I mean it works it
gets headlines I guess but um I don't
know so I think that there's a video
game called alone in the dark and I
think he made an adaptation of it which
of course is terrible like all his
movies are but this movie is nothing to
do with that this movie actually came
out in
1982 I heard about it a couple of months
back like somebody recommended it on one
of those underrated 80s horror movies or
whatever sites and I and I was like man
look at that [__] cast this has Jack
Palance Donald Pleasant and Martin
landow and the dude that played what's
his face from The Running Man uh yeah he
played uh Electro Electro yeah from uh
the heavy set guy Dwight sh no is that
his name I can't remember I don't know
he just that heavy set guy who could
sing on yeah yeah the big dude that yeah
that was in the running man because I
was just like hey I know that guy man it
makes me want to see that again well I
think it's on it I think it's on Amazon
Prime for free [__] I got that [__] on
Blu-ray we can watch it after the show
if you want to I don't care yeah every
time I see that [__] movie man I get
Nostalgia for it and Lil swo is going
back to New York so I won't be seeing
him around he made a whole nostalgic
video I posted it on U Tom shitty movies
anded my newsfeed on um on uh Facebook
and it's got the his 15 years here in
Florida it's got him and his New York
friends and in the background's got
[__] the uh the soundtrack in the
back's got music that was relevant in a
time that the video clip came from it's
got a lot of me and Jen in it it's got
um Kaye before she died and then all
those other girls like Jillian and [__]
that he was hanging out with yeah
they're all in it it's a good little
clip it's pretty fun yeah I like relived
like 15 years
Thomas flashback nostalgic about it like
damn every time I see myself man I
looked [__] young as [__] had hair
and
everything well I mean you still have
hair I got hair you just shave it up you
just shave it up yeah wish there is not
as good as it used to be that's all it
is Danny rling said smart thinking on
the double feature review hopefully more
to come yeah it's like I don't want to
get into a thing where it's like now I
feel pressured to like watch two movies
but sometimes you know if we're not
doing anything over the weekend or
something or if it's still early and we
watch a movie and it's like ah [__] it
let's watch another one like sometimes
we'll watch two and they're both like
worth talking about yeah these are be
movies so it doesn't take long to cover
them right right right yeah so they're
not like artistic masterpieces where you
have to like kind of go and like write a
dissertation about the [__] you know
just something you can drink and watch
these and [__] laugh yeah they're
pretty good they're good although I'm
going to say like alone in the dark like
I said so this came out in ' 82 now it's
usually um classed as a
slasher which it kind of is this is
really interesting because I don't
usually like watch the trailers for
movies and stuff like that before I
watch them but for this one for whatever
reason um this might I don't not really
sure where this movie is streaming I
just watched it on YouTube cuz somebody
uploaded it for free on there like a
decent copy and it just so happened that
somebody had put the would had you know
uploaded the trailer to so I was like oh
[__] it I'll watch the trailer cuz I was
waiting him for him to come out of the
bathroom or something and the trailer
for this movie makes it look like a
completely different [__] movie which
I guess a lot of trailers do that don't
they even back even back then they did
it they do it now too talking about now
alone in the dark the Donald Pleasant
one I didn't see the trailer I don't
think yeah I think you were in the
bathroom like I said I was just watching
it cuz I was [__] around but the
trailer for this like all the scenes in
the trailer are indeed in the movie but
the context for them is completely
different I think they were trying to
make it look more like a standard 880s
slasher and this isn't
really a slasher it kind of is no it's
not but not really it's more like
something that Carpenter would have made
almost like a salt on Precinct 13 thas
saying this is a lot more like a
carpenter movie yeah like it's not as
good as a carpenter movie but it's still
pretty it's odd it's just a very odd
movie feel like Carpenter type stuff
then this this is there with it yeah
where you know there's a dab and
basically a mental hospital it's called
The Haven yeah it's in thean Asylum yeah
yeah yeah and the people that own it are
letting the letting the lunatics run the
Asylum they're yeah kind of they have
trustees and stuff and a power outage
happens and the crazy people think one
guy thinks he did it they have a big
Riot breaks out crazy people get out and
then they they run around in the damn
gang and create Mayhem and uh you know
it's like something out of carpenter or
you know or if you ever seen VFW which
is a carpenter likee film it's like that
VFW is much better but oh and if you
haven't seen VFW please watch VFW VFW
piece especially if you like Carpenter
flick it's very carpenteri right so you
this is kind of like a fake Carpenter
movie kind of like especially in the
second half yeah cuz I feel like it's
almost kind of like divided into two
halves cuz like the first half like
Donald Pleasants plays a dude named Dr
Bane
and he runs this Asylum now at first
when I was watching the movie um I
thought now is he one of the patients
and they're just like letting him run
the [__] but no he's an actual doctor
and I discovered on Wikipedia that he
his character is actually kind of based
on a real dude um who was his big
philosophy was the one of the ways to
treat um insanity or treat mental
illness was to kind of I don't know if
I'd say encourage it but he I don't know
he had like some unorthodox methods
let's put it like that so so Donald
Pleasant's character is based on that
character so he runs this
Asylum almost as though he's kind of
like fostering their delusions a little
bit cuz there's one really funny scene
where this lady is coming up and she's
telling him that she thinks that her
intestines are coming out and strangling
her or something like that and he like
totally acts like that's legit and
that's real and how how she can stop him
from doing that you know what I mean so
it's almost like encouraging their
delusions and he thinks that's going to
make them get better and it's like so
most of the people in there are like not
you know dangerous or anything so he
just kind of lets him run loose and he's
kind of crazy too and he's just like
constantly high like he's like smoking
pot through the whole thing like it
seemed like but there is this one kind
of higher security floor which is like
the third floor and these guys are kind
of like the dangerous dudes like there's
like a child molester and you know like
a murderer and stuff like that
and they are actually locked up but
Donald Pleasants actually just calls
them voyagers you know what I mean like
rather than crazy people or whatever
Psychopaths or whatever so um it so
happens that a new doctor comes to this
hospital and for whatever reason one of
the guys on the third floor he's played
by Jack Palance gets it in his head that
the new doctor killed the old one right
the in reality the old one just moved to
another hospital they got another job
but they get the idea that the new
doctor has killed the old one so they
decide like all the dangerous lunatics
decide that they're going to kill the
doctor that they're going to get out
somehow and then it so happens that
there's kind of like a townwide
blackout and because the psychopaths are
behind like this electronically
controlled door or whatever they all get
out and start running around in the
street and they
specifically Target the home of the
doctor and like his family like his wife
and his daughter and I think his sister
his sister is also staying there too um
who's like older and she and she has
like some mental problems too like she
had a nervous breakdown and she just got
out so there's that whole subplot also
so this was actually directed by a guy
named um Jack Scher I think is how you
pronounce his last name he also directed
uh Freddy's uh night El Street 2 quote
quote the gay one he directed that one
Freddy's Revenge uh also directed
wishmas 2o in a movie called The Hidden
which I think I've seen but I can't
really remember much about it um so this
was actually his first movie his was
directorial debut so this like I said
it's very carpent it's very John
Carpenter another interesting thing
about this movie is that one of the
lunatics that escapes um who's like a I
think he's like a serial killer or like
a rapist or Strang he's a Strangler
right serial killer he's called the
bleeder because his nose bleeds like
when he attacks women and you don't see
his face like At first cuz he's like has
a weird thing about that so when they
get out and they loot start looting [__]
and like picking up weapons and stuff he
puts on a hockey mask right like Jason
like Jason now there's kind of like a
bone of contention about this because
this movie came out
before Friday the 13th 3 which was the
first one that had Jason in the hockey
mask right but I think this was being
shot at around the same time so a lot of
people have been like well one did RI
did one rip off the other one or you
know was it just a weird coincidence
that he just happened to put a it
doesn't look exactly the same as the
Jason hockey mask it's slightly
different had a bunch of different hoty
masks and they just picked one yeah so a
lot of people have kind of pointed that
out they're like wow that's really weird
that like they just came out maybe they
maybe they were shooting him at at
roughly the same time and the heard
about what you know put a hocke mask the
other movie is doing that it's a good it
looks really cool yeah I'll put a hockey
mask on you probably know it would
become iconic I guess not yeah because
the first two Friday the 13th movies
like well the well the first one
obviously his mom was the killer spoiler
alert and the second one he had a
[__] burlap sack over his yeah burlap
bag with a hole in it yeah so he didn't
even go which like the Phantom killer of
Tex Arcana which I thought I thought
that was where they got that idea from
but yeah so he didn't get the hockey
Master the third movie so I think this
this movie actually came out before the
third movie did so I L those movies when
I was [__] young man I did to one two
and three I still like them I still like
them I got them I got them on Blu-ray
they're a lot of fun they're a lot of
fun to watch they're not as gory as I
remembered them they're really not it's
if you watch them now they're very tame
yeah and they're also not very scary no
when I was a kid they were [__]
scared the [__] out of me be looking out
looking out the window at night hoping
that I wouldn't see anybody looking at
looking
ining
funny
yeah yeah Tammy says what his mom LOL
yeah yeah sorry sorry to burst your
bubble on that uh Ben says have you ever
done a show on postal or U ball in
general no but we probably should but
like I said he might want to kick our
asses then yeah I've never really seen
any of his
movies I don't think I have either um
I've heard about him just tangentially
because a lot of people kind of like you
know give him [__] and stuff but he's
kind of and maybe he's made other movies
too I don't really know but I feel like
he's kind of mostly known for making bad
video game adapation he came my
attention when people were slamming him
over blood rain how bad the movie Blood
rain was but I've never seen how bad
could it be we got to see it really I
guess we got to see it I well see I
guess I have like
um I'm a lot more tolerant of like that
cuz like sometimes people say like oh my
God this movie is like the worst [__]
thing ever and I watch it and I'm just
like it wasn't that bad you know what I
mean it's just like it was just mediocre
because it's I guess because I watched
so much MST and I was like you want to
see some [__] bad movies there's some
[__] bad movies on there they were
just made like with a [__] you know
watch man the hands and I think had uh
either Udo Kier in it or the guy [__]
well now see that makes me want to watch
it because I love it or or it had the
the bald guy what's his name he was in
that gangster movie the bald guy in the
gang the British gangster movie the bald
guy
uh he's an older guy's
bald
um you're not really helping kind of a
foreign name you're not narrowing it
down he played the Pharaoh in [__] in
one the Storia Joseph made for
TV oh [__] what the [__] is that dude's
name I know who you're talking about
what the [__] is that [__] name
rich guy but I don't know if he what the
[__] is that [__] I forgot that
guy's name Danny Ry said is it Ben
Kingsley yeah Ben Ben Kingsley there you
go exactly I I also love Ben King yeah I
think blood rain has Ben King Ben King I
think you might be right about that
actually he got it Ben Ben Kingsley
that's right well I figured somebody was
going to know yeah one of these days
we'll watch this movie watch that movie
and review it cuz I'm kind of curious
although I kind of feel like look if
you're going to make a movie it either
has to be really good or like great or
it has to be like so shitty that it's
like really entertaining like if it's
just in between it's just going to fall
in the crack you know what I mean and I
kind of feel like I think I'll be
disappointed if I watch this movie that
so many people say oh my God it's so
terrible and then I watch it and it's
just me you know what I mean I'm like I
want it to be like just [__]
outrageously
terrible you gotta like you got to get
one extreme or the other I can't I can't
answer it Jen I
got i' I played the game blood rain and
I think blood rain too I liked them yeah
Xbox the old Xbox I thought they were
great games then I'd heard through the
Great Vine that they made a move it was
terrible and I didn't bother seeing it I
kind of feel like until recently most
most adaptations they made of video
games were pretty terrible yeah I think
he did a bunch of Resident Evil movies I
think that had what's her name in it
that girl from wait did he make the
Resident Evil movies cuz those actually
well now I've only seen like the first
one or two and those it wasn't they
weren't that bad those too although I
saw one of the later ones or part of one
of the later ones and it was pretty
sucky that had that Eastern European
chick in it yeah yeah I know I know what
you're talking about one from fifth El
yeah I can't remember her name either
I'll remember in a second but um I don't
even think I watched the whole thing
like it wasn't like I said it wasn't
egregiously terrible I was just kind of
like me you know what I mean Ben says uh
postal is amazingly
good is it okay I don't believe
you but I might watch it anyway um Danny
Rowling said Donald Pleasants did a good
job in the 1988 Italian Gallo style film
by rero diod Phantom of death it's got
ninjas in it too I've actually heard of
that but I don't think I've seen it yeah
cuz he were did a lot of films in Italy
he did some shitty ones like Puma man
and he also did pretty good ones like
that Dario Argento movie the agenda
we're talking about Puma man we were
just talking about Puma the only
Superman movie where where the superhero
wears slacks yeah from from JC Penny
yeah it's like his mom Dr
Fu now I was like now I kind of want to
watch the MST of Puma man again they had
a [__] field day with that movie
[__] they're saying all kind of stuff
[__] I know I'm getting behind yeah
you're getting behind
uh Silent Hill is a pretty good movie
yeah I agree um I like Silent Hill and
uh yes might have been was Silent Hill
or Resident Evil I don't knowbody is I
don't remember but see I don't I don't
think I don't think that German dude
made those though CU I think those were
actually like pretty decent yeah Ben
said he specializes in computer game
adaptations blood rain postal something
about a king okay something but uh yeah
he said that the girl from Blood rain
what was her name uh Mill Jovovich no
the girl from Blood rain oh um where
go facebody I think um I don't see what
you're looking at it's gone I don't see
what you're looking at no no right there
Christina Lo blood raid blood where are
you seeing that I don't see it I may
maybe I'm behind
testicles big though or chesticles were
they big though that was that's the
thing and we'll get into that when we
talk about the next movie we show them
all day long they're not big you know
Tom's just like man man mine are bigger
he's not impressed [__] bigger he's out
deess with your with your small
chesticle yeah yeah
yeah oh my God yeah
um what oh slash friend said in the 90s
there was a nightmare on Elm Street
Nintendo game yeah I remember that and
also a Friday the 13th Nintendo game I
it makes me laugh that like in the 80s
and 90s there was so much like uh Friday
the 13th stuff in nightwear and El
streets stuff that was like marketed to
kids I just there was like a friday3
ripoff arcade game called splatter house
[__] loved it oh yeah yeah you played
Jason going through a haunted house
fighting [__] all kinds of monsters
you can pick up weapons and fight them
you're fighting all these you know you
didn't get to you didn't get to kill
Camp counselors uhuh you're in hell
that's a shame you're in hell in this
[__] haunted house they probably have
a game like that nowadays I would
imagine yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know
I I don't know 's not real enthused no I
guess maybe maybe when we talk about the
next movie you'll get more enthused cuz
there's boobies in it but um but yeah so
the okay so alone in the dark I didn't
love it I thought there were some pacing
issues but I like that it was kind of
like a slasher but they did some
different [__] with it you know what I'm
saying and it also has like a real good
twist which I'm not going to spoil
because I think a lot of people have not
seen this which I actually didn't
realize was a Twist until later you know
kind of cuz I I don't know I was paying
attention but maybe not really so I was
just kind of like oh oh I didn't and and
also I'm not sure if I love the ending
like I
get I get what he was trying to say with
it you know what I mean but the ending
was just kind of like oh uh okay you
know what I mean it was just that kind
of thing like I get what he was trying
to say also I like that there was a band
called the sick [__] in this yeah which
uh yeah they go to this nightclub and
the
sister the first time the sister in the
what's what was her character's name
Tony I think was her name and she shows
up to visit her brother and
sister-in-law and she is wearing the
most 80s outfit that has ever 80ss in
the'80s yeah I mean it was like the
whole full on like Stripes i she think
she had leg warmers I think she had like
her hair pulled off in a ponytail to one
side with like pink streaks in it purple
jacket with orange trim or it was it was
something else cuz I was just like wow
that is Peak 80s right there
asymmetrical glasses that look like a
damn triangle did she have those yeah I
think remember like I think she had I
might have had a pair of those when I
was really little yeah like that
somebody gave to me or something like
that but yeah so they go to this
nightclub which I think what is it
called stumps or something like that
with which also is like the most pointy
like' 880s kind of font imaginable and
you go in there and there's this band
and they
had the like one of them had they had
like a big like papier-mâché Axe and
like then one of them had like a big
papier-mâché machete or something like
that I want to say and then they were
doing a song about like chopping people
up or something I I couldn't really
understand the lyrics but um but yeah so
the so the super 80 sister she gets in
the mosh pit in the beginning which was
like a pretty cuz I even said I was like
that's a pretty weak sauce uh Mosh Pit I
don't think anyone's gonna get her in
there it's just everyone's just kind of
jumping around you know what I mean but
they were trying to show that the sister
is like oh man she's like so she's so
crazy it was that kind of thing because
I think kind of the the point of the
movie and you know what they were trying
to say at the end was that cuz they I
think they even had this in the dialogue
too where they were just saying oh you
know the crazy people that are in the
Asylum it's just like oh it's crazier
out there you know what I mean so I
think they were kind of trying to push
that home which I'm not really sure if
they were successful in doing that but I
don't know like if you like weird
slashers I wouldn't call this a slasher
outright don't go into this expecting a
slasher and if you watch the trailer the
movie is really nothing like that like I
said all of the scenes in the trailer
are indeed in the movie but it's not um
it's not anything like the trailer makes
it look it's it's trying to look like a
standard teen
slasher because try to sell it focuses
on the younger characters like it shows
the sex scene between um what was that
like the babysitter's name Binky or
whatever her name was like her and her
boyfriend like having sex or something
like that she was like it literally that
was like the only scene she was in I
think she was only in like one or two
scenes she wasn't like a big character
or anything they just used her to sell a
movie right so so they focused on that
kind of stuff and they didn't Focus
hardly at all on Donald Pleasants or
Martin landow or um or Jack palet who
were kind of more the main characters
them and like the doctor guy and his
wife and their kid who were like the
main characters star/
hasband you couldn't get the young
horror crowd into that into a movie to
watch those guys they were sick of them
those are the dudes you see on
television yeah it's like here's this
but here's this here's this scene with
like this blonde chick that's only in
the movie for like two minutes yeah come
see the movie like having sex with her
boyfriend on the bed and then them
getting murdered so there's that yeah
but um but yeah so it does have slasher
like scenes in there and probably the
second half of it like you said is
almost kind of like assault on preing 13
It's like a Siege yeah kind of thing
because the doctor and his wife and the
um and their daughter the daughter is an
awesome character by the way their
little nerdy daughter her name is Laya
or something um and she's like real
funny she's like real uh sarcastic kind
of like salt on Precinct 13 and and
Halloween had a baby kind of and they're
and they're all kind of like so they're
all holed up in the house like while all
these Maniacs are like outside like kind
of trying to get in you know what I mean
so the second half is kind of like that
so don't go into it like thinking it's a
slasher cuz it's not exactly but it's
interesting like I think they did like
some interesting [__] with it and it's
surely it's it's really kind of like um
pretty original for the time it's just
interesting to me how they marketed it
even the poster kind of looks like a
slasher movie it's just like a like a
leg with a somebody carrying an axe or
something like that which like I said
that does happen in the movie but it's
not you could take this Movie remake it
and make a [__] cool ass movie for no
money you could actually this is It's a
good concept yeah it's a good concept
executed right yeah they didn't have any
money that's part of it like I said I
liked this movie I didn't love it it's a
great idea I thought it just I thought
it just had some pacing issues was I
think my major issue take this [__] I'd
take something like this and spice it up
and re-edit it and shoot it with the
right uh um soundtrack or you know or
score and make it a fake Carpenter flick
kind of like VFW that's what I would do
with
it yeah if it had a carpenter type score
score it it have been
great and I mean honestly like I said if
you're going to remake a movie yeah this
one is one that I don't know if it's
totally forgotten or anything like that
cuz it did get kind of a nice Blu-ray
release and everything like a like a
while back but um you know people still
kind of remember it but it's still
pretty Niche it's still pretty cult so I
feel like if you're going to remake
something maybe make something like this
cuz like I said it's kind of a good idea
to like think of these like four
lunatics essentially and one of them I
mean Jack pal his character he's kind of
like the the ring leader sort of and
he's the one whose idea it is so they
all are kind of going to do what he says
you know what I mean so he just like and
they all bust out like during a blackout
so I think that's kind of like a cool
idea and then I there was also some kind
of like um misdirect I think because one
of the characters the guy like the
electro guy from The Running Man um he
was like a child molester and they did a
little bit with that that I thought was
kind of cleverly also known as a PDF
file a PDF file yeah Bea that's one of
my that's one of my favorite keep from
getting that's one of my favorite you
like calling them a PDF file I don't
know who came up with that but that's
like really funny that I first heard of
that like a long time ago but yeah it's
a decent flick I don't know what
streaming service is on I just watch it
on YouTube but I'm assuming that since
they I don't know if it was Shout
Factory or arrow that put it out but
somebody put out like a nice Blu-ray of
it not too long ago cuz I know a lot of
people reviewed it probably like a year
or two back um so I don't know how long
it's going to be up on YouTube that's
what I'm saying because somebody might
be like hey what's that doing there
fresh looking it's not HD or anything
right right right so yeah it's not like
fantastic but it's decent it was it was
decent looking but it might be like
streaming elsewhere I'd imagine and it's
totally worth watching like if you're
into 80 slashers but with a different
thing going on that'll like have a kind
of carpenter kind of vibe to him it's
not fantastic but I don't know I really
liked it and it had like some weird
imagery and like I said [__] Donald
Pleasants is I've seen a couple reviews
of this and they said he's almost like
the anti-d Lumis yeah kind of like cuz
he's still like a psychiatrist but he's
kind of
loopy and he's having fun with it with
the role it seems like he never founds
it in he does J he never does and that's
what landow did a good job too actually
Martin landow is terrifying in this
[__]
movie I think I think one of the things
and I can't remember if you guys
remember in this was like a long time
ago but remember Bravo the channel did
Bravo's 100 scariest movie moments and
then they did like 100 more scaries
movie or something else something like
that I'm pretty sure that the scene
where Martin landow comes to the
doctor's house and says he's got a
telegram like he's got the hat that he
took from the from the postal guy that
he ran over and he like is trying to get
the wife to let him in I'm pretty sure
that was on there because when that
scene came in the movie I was like I
have seen this scene before like
multiple times so this must have turned
up on some like scariest movie scene
list because Martin landow looks like
holy [__] like if he turned up at my
[__] doorstep looking like that
probably just shoot him on General
principle now we called that other guy
Electro the guy who played in in in
running man I don't think that's what
his name in Running Man was I think it
was Dynamo oh yeah yeah yeah you're
right it was Dynamo yeah you're right he
could shoot electricity he had damn dune
buggy could sing opera and yeah he was
an opera singer I remember that yeah it
was the same dude because we recognized
him he plays a [__] frightening
character in this he is yeah big ass
baby he he like PDF 5 yeah yeah yeah and
it's pretty creepy yeah it's pretty
creepy gets his hands on a little girl
talks to her it's [__] weird yeah
let's go up to your room and I'll show
you how I can make anything with paper
yeah right yeah and I'm just like oh
no he does kill her no no he didn't kill
her she shows up alive later yeah
doesn't she that's right yeah cuz they
lead you to believe that he killed her
that's what I mean they did like a lot
of really
I'm like Donal Pleasant because he just
aely loopy weirdo and I was kind of and
um but I'm gonna say like I think Martin
landow kind of steals the show although
Jack Palance is pretty scary in this too
because he plays like a total psycho
also yeah um but Martin landow just like
the facial expressions he makes and [__]
like that is just so [__] creepy it's
a low budget movie so [__] creepy but
every one of these actors has been in
much lower budget movies than this oh
yeah so this is actually one of the
better ones you know one of the better
lowbudget movies that these guys have
been in yeah it's like a it's like a
carpenter flick so you know it's all
right it's good yeah I didn't yeah I
didn't mind it I thought it was it could
have been fixed I'd have put a better
score on it um had to put [__] the
thing is it's not a carpenter movie yeah
I'd make it sound like a carpenter movie
and edit it to be like a carpenter movie
then you did would it' be it'd be better
yeah yeah Ben says who is the better
psychiatrist Dr Lumis or Dr Lecter and
tamy said at least Dr Lumis wouldn't eat
you yeah that's kind of a point in his
favor leor lecor ate you because you
deserved it though he only ate you if
you were rude yeah the free range what
do mean is it he ate bad guys see uh See
see uh what was it Hannibal Rising that
gives his backstory it's a [__] great
movie I mean everybody that gets Aid in
that probably had a common yeah it's
great but he's basically a very evil
Batman basically is what he is like a
vigilante yeah he's like a vigilante
yeah hunting down war criminals and
eating them because they killed his
daughter or his sister sister his little
his baby sister yeah and it's a [__]
ate her and they ate her yeah and he is
like from a rich [__] aristocratic
family up in [__] they were from
Lithuania I think were they he was a
Lithuanian something like that and then
he was related to uh some French royalty
or not royalty nobility
and uh ended up going to his uncle's
house when he ran across back across the
Iron Curtain it turned out his uncle had
died but he started living with her with
his widow with his uncle's Widow who was
a Japanese Aristocrat what was his name
lady miraki I think is what her name was
and she taught him how to [__] run a
sword in basically the way of the the
basically the way of the the warrior and
[__] some [__] moushi and he became a
primitive one man Warrior who ate people
who were
bad you know and it's where he came from
in between the the Germans and the
Soviet Union fighting in this no man's
land where people were starving to death
and people were eating each other he was
just a monster as they do he was he he
learned picked us up as a little kid so
it's it's great see Hannibal Rising and
I think it's a French movie but it's all
in English I think the French made it it
got a bunch of awards man it's it's a
period piece and the [__] all the way
down to the motorcycles and the and the
guns and the [__] and the the the the
clothes that they're wearing a [__]
Russian t34 shows up the way the tank
shows up and I looked at it man the
detail was superb it was exactly like a
t34 that you'd see on the Eastern front
it they even had a bicycle strapped to
the [__] turret when they did that
because when the tanks parked you can't
drive the tank down and go get a [__]
bottle of wine or anything you had to
ride a bicycle that's what the tank grew
riding bicycles around when the tanks
toart which that's you know [__]
great detail and [__] strapped to the
side of the
tank genx Jason said I'm down to one
marijuana cigarette a day and I saved it
today for this show good a thank you
very much I appreciate that smoke up uh
Oracle said Jack Palance didn't have to
work too hard to be scary as [__] that
is absolutely true he's creepy he was
kind of creepy although like I said
Martin landow was like aund times
creepier Jack pal was he didn't look
creepy when that styrofoam hit him in
the head though
you know exactly Jack Palance was yeah I
do Jack Palance was also in some
questionable movies but like I said hey
actors got to eat too man and it's just
kind of like they're probably not happy
about it either but they're just kind of
like hey whatever it's a paycheck so you
got to show up and do the [__] yeah what
the [__] was that um Outlaw of Gore
Outlaw yeah it was a bottom it was an
Italian sci-fi movie based on like a I
think it was a series of comic books and
he wears this ridiculous hat that on MST
they called it his split Top butter top
hat and uh he's in the [__] he's in
the bridge of some spaceship wasn't it
no it he was like in his wizard cave or
whatever cave yeah there's not it's not
spaceship he goes to like another
dimension that's like a old that's like
sword and sorcery starts collapsing on
him and [__] the walls are falling in
and dirt and [__] [__] one of the
beams comes and hits him it's a big old
thing of Styrofoam bounces off his head
very obviously styrofoam and he and he
plays it off like it didn't happen he
just stays in character stays character
through the whole thing like I said I
admire that bounces off his
wig or that no it was a giant hat he was
wearing it's like this ridiculous
[__] it's a ridiculous [__] hat
that was also another good MST episode
Outlaw of Gore oh my God but is all
those [__] 80s like sword and sword
and sorcery like sword and sandal movies
were like so [__] they were all Conan
ripoffs don't see any of those just see
Conan unless you watch the MST versions
those areth watching the only other
Conan ripoff that's is watchable is
Conan 2 which is the Conan
ripoff yeah well it's got Arnold in it
and everything but it's not the same
director yeah and it's like a cone and
ripoff yeah Oracle said the gore series
was a set of novels written by John
Norman yeah that's right uh and
reportedly it started out as money maker
then he started uh believing his own
crap yeah well that's that's what happen
you get too much into that okay let's
get to the second oh wait a minute wait
a minute uh couple more a couple more
fun facts about alone in the dark that I
had forgotten about right was that I
think this was the the first movie
produced by the famous new lion Cinema
who later became uh very known for the
Nightmare and Elm Street movies they
actually even called it the house that
Freddy built because that was where they
made all their money um also the
director had also been the editor on the
1981 slasher movie The Burning uh which
also Tom savini worked on so there's
that as well also the original version
for this was supposed to involve the
mafia but it's like they didn't have the
budget so they're like well we'll just
make it like a home invasion kind of
thing that's cheaper cuz we can just
like shoot in house yeah we don't need
the mafia but so so we don't need like
all the mafia and all that kind of like
business so yeah so that's what that was
supposed to be but yeah like so it's on
YouTube still at least as the day that
we're talking um but it's probably like
somewhere else too but it's absolutely
worth watching I thought it was like
pretty good it's weird but it's like
pretty good so this second movie so
we're scrolling through Amazon Prime
last night or freey or whatever it was
and we're looking at the horror movies
that are free to watch and I saw this I
actually watched the trailer for this
the other day I'm like oh my God this
looks this looks hysterical we should
totally drink and watch this one night
so last night we decided this isight I
said do you want to watch slave girls
from beyond Infinity so I showed him the
trailer and he's like oh my God we
absolutely have to watch that
yeah the trailer was great the trailer
great the trailer was in a way better
than the movie but the movie was pretty
good too yeah yeah yeah the trailer is
lot doing a lot of lying about what kind
of movie it is that's what it seems to
be a common theme it's just these hot
chicks
in leather bikinis or fake leather bik
not leather what do you call it rawh
hide bikinis like I think they're
supposed to be rabbit skin rabbit skin
or something [__] they're in they're
chained up and they're just these
victims and [__] this dude is
assaulting them and they're just it's
got a voice over about how you know
[__] hot they are and how much
they're going to be [__] assaulted
and [__] it's just it's fun how much of
assaulting there's going to be yeah how
much assaulting there's going to be
and then they go it's a it's it's a big
movie it's got big [__] this and big
that and then [__] they show like a
uh what was it big uh [__] uh what
was it effects or something big was it
big adventure no it's a big scale or
something they're showing like outer
space [__] the ship going through
outer space and they go and big girls
and it's got [__] one chick she's
sitting up [__] just big old boobs
and [__]
you can't see him because really cuz
she's behind a like a bed curtain G
thing and you know they're [__]
fighting and [__] they got swords it
looks like Barbarian girls you know in
space there's robots in it yeah I got to
see this one I was like yeah this looks
this looks like one right and it starts
instantly they're [__] getting
running through the [__] jungle in
the middle of the night and with the
boing boing
Bo
get captur bik yeah she gets captured
next thing you know they're in like the
[__] slave pin in the
spaceship and or whatever yeah or
whatever they're chained to the wall
they break out there's two hotties in
there and uh they got very different
builds one's tall and skinny the other
one's kind of shorter and more
voluptuous they look like the the
perfect heavy metal girlfriends for 1987
they like heavy metal heavy metal girl
they that real fried blonde hair that
everybody that they all had in the 80s
this was ' 87 by this came out and
they're supposed to be kind of like
Savages okay but they they hard they
don't even have shoes okay they're
hardcore yeah they just got these
[__] buck skin [__] bikinis and
[__] all right but strangely enough they
got hair products they got [__] their
hair is [__] perfect they got makeup
makeups on they're [__] I was like
where are they keeping that [__] like up
their ass yeah little little is that lip
gloss baby little perfect Pedic where's
your conditioner perfect pedicured feet
let get they're running around Barefoot
but they got pedicured feet and [__]
[__] I love that yeah
well quickly though they escaped from
the [__] prison ship it turns out
that it it's totally set totally
different from the from
the from the trailer yeah times like I
think the trailer was just like the
first couple minutes of the movie yeah
it goes in like a different Direction
when they made the trailer and it was
very deceptive about what kind of movie
it's going to be turns out the girls are
actually competent they know how to fly
spaceships they like that though yeah
yeah they're kind they're they're
they're they're they're pretty
heroic um they're Brave and [__] yeah
they're actually really smart and like
really resourceful and stuff so they
didn't just like they look like bimbos
and they kind of film them like they're
bimbos but they don't act like bimbos
and uh turns out that you know they they
escape like in an escape ship and
they're trying figure out what Planet
they should go to to run and they go to
some planet and it sucks them in on a
tractor beam basically and it crashes
them and uh and they're like Well turns
out they got this U hot ass [__]
bachelor in his [__] living there
with his [__] castle and he likes to
[__] hunt people to death there's
already people there and [__] that he's
getting ready to hunt and you realize
real quickly that this is a retelling of
the most dangerous game down to [__]
down to [__] the philosophy and a lot
of the they have made so many
adaptations the most dangerous game and
most of them weren't even called that
right like I saw they did one on MST
that was called blood lust it had the
dad from The Brady Bunch in it like way
before the Brady Bunch cuz I think it
was like late 50s um it was called
bloodlust but it was very clearly most
dangerous game yeah and it really
started to remind me of the uh The Most
Dangerous Game episode from the Logan's
Run Series yeah it is kind of like but
with extra hot girls in it it was kind
of like yeah they had three hotties in
there
and a dude he gets killed and then the
guy's got an army of these
robots that like to see chicks take
their clothes off it's a [__] bizarre
flick I like I liked it here was the
thing like so the dude the oily guy that
owns the yeah the most dangerous game
Planet cuz apparently he's the only
person that lives there like it's his
private Game Preserve or whatever and
he's got like all yeah he's got like all
the paneling and all the heads on the
wall and he's all slick he's actually
pretty shredded he's a good-looking guy
he kind of looks like that dude kind of
looks like that dude dude you know that
dude he looked real familiar and I was
like Batman oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah he
looks like um Christian Bale B he looks
a little bit like Christian Bale I was
just kind of like because I kept making
um American Psycho jokes like when I saw
him also he looked a little bit like
with his slick back hair and his like
tight vinyl pants or whatever they were
I said he looked he looked a little bit
like Nick Cave In The Mercy Seat video
from 1988 except I think Nick Cave was
like much better looking and he had like
a red shirt on but it was kind of like a
same it was the same VI I was getting
that Vibe and as it goes on it's
actually got some pretty
decent mat shots and um yeah this was
much better than I was expecting I was
expecting it to just be yeah I mean it's
low budget low budget it's trashy trashy
fun but it's fun trashy yeah and it's
competently shot it's not you know like
I said I've seen way [__] wor and
you're going to see these two chicks run
around [__] scantily clad
inappropriately for the situation
they're run around constantly in [__]
night gowns that you can see through
bras and panties for no reason for no
reason you know and they never have
shoes they're [__] barefit through
the whole [__] thing and not a single
catus on the bottom of their feet their
feet they'll go through that in the
woods and [__] [__] being hunted and
[__] survive and come back and get
back in the castle and kick a
motherfucker's ass and their feet aren't
even dirty yep just perfect pedicured
[__] feet and they look like they
steep right out of a damn heavy metal
video like a white snake video or some
[__]
crew video but the cool thing about this
movie is that even though everybody is
kind of taking it seriously they're kind
of not at the same time it's a fantasy
time like they all look like they're
having a good time like shooting the
movie but not to a point where it's just
where they're winking at the audience if
that makes any sense you know what I
mean what I liked about it is it was
pretty
fast-paced I mean it's pretty short I
think it was only 75 minutes yeah it was
pretty
fast-paced they show you a lot of [__]
you do laugh at a lot of [__] that they
show you it kind of makes sense it no
the the no the the story is actually
very uh well told it's very basic though
it's it's a very basic story they're
retelling most dangerous
game the girls are cute the dude the bad
guy's hot so if you're if you're a chick
you get to see that he [__] sexually
[__] Sexes them up and [__] uh so
there kind of a BDSM element in a couple
that it's like a heavy metal [__]
it's kind of like a heavy metal sword
and
sorcery interplanetary fantasy kind of
like something out of the magazine heavy
metal it's kind of like that it kind of
reminded me of that kind of like
something out of the old Heavy Metal
magazine uh which has nothing to do with
heavy metal music it was just uh you
know it's like something you'd see there
where they're mixing a bunch of genres
together like fantasy and
sci-fi I mean [__] she even shows up
dressed as a gladiator at one point
[__] fire and what I did like about
it is that yeah man there's grur this
there isn't a lot of nudity in it but
there's a lot not like real like there's
boobies like you get see like straight
up titties but you don't there's no Bush
there's no no no male nudity no nothing
no real sex as shown not really it's
pretty tame yeah it's very tame but but
those girl those girls are running
around scandy clad from nice good angles
they know who the market is yeah the
audience is teenage boys yeah who like
heavy metal and uh they got it right
yeah yeah I don't know I mean it just it
it made me laugh so much when okay so um
the two ladies that are in this um
alizabeth uh Katan I think is how you
pronounce it Katan something like that
um there actually three of them but the
two I know but I yeah the two main
characters two blondes um I actually
recognized her immediately I'm like this
this chick was in lots of movies I
recognized her from Friday the 13th 7
she was in that she was also in twins
she was also in night wish yeah she
she's a scream Queen and she was in
assault of the killer Bim
other yeah she's cute she's real cute
and she can act enough adequately yeah
both the girls can the acting in this
one like I said it's you know it's not
great but not bad it's yeah it's fine
I've seen much worse I've seen much
worse this is kind of like and they look
like they're having a good time like I
said this is 1987's version of an asylum
flick but there's something kind of a
little more Charming about it because
it's retro now I was Charmed I mean I
just like I said because they know they
seem to know like how ridiculous it is
and they're not winking at the audience
but they're just like ah we're just
going to have fun with this you know
what like yeah obviously I'm going to go
out in the forest like hunting for
something in like a tiny little white
nighty and no shoes yeah and not can
come back after that and be clean I'll
be still clean yeah and it's just you
know one chei went out to seduce the
damn robots into the [__] water and
didn't go but halfway up her Shin in the
water didn't even get wet yeah okay I
was like you know that she told the
director she's like I'm not getting my
hair W get in there I'm not getting in
the ocean there's [__] sharks in
there [__] that I don't I'm not getting
paid enough for this sorry [__] funny
yeah and she's out there and that that
was funny too cuz the other girl who's
played by Cindy Beal she was real funny
too she's like real sarcastic and um we
were kind of making I know this is mean
but we were kind of like making jokes
about um well I was making jokes because
Elizabeth ktan obviously has bigger
boobs than Cindy Beal did so I I think
I'm not sure if this was this joke but
there was a joke later on in the movie
where they had the map to this Temple
thing that they were supposed to get to
because the dude was Haunting them it's
a long story so so Elizabeth kanan's
character who was what was her [__]
name um the the other one was Tissa
Daria Daria yeaha Daria was Elizabeth K
tan so she had the map and she put it in
tisa's bra yeah and then she said you
need this more than I do and I'm like
[__] I'm like was that I was like did
she just tell her that was she just
making a joke about her being flat
because I'm like one that's hilarious
but two that's like kind of mean two she
wasn't totally flat she wasn't totally
flat no she was just flat in comparison
to so we kind of made a joke because
it's and then when they made that joke
I'm like oh they seem to be aware that
her boobs aren't as big as and Elizabeth
katan's boobs were just like regular
size they weren't like a normas or
anything they like me yeah Tom Tom knows
he's a boobology yeah yeah were were
probably like a small SE [__] the the
other one what was the name no Daria was
the was the one with was the short one
the bigger Bo yeah she's probably like a
small C the other one was like a bee all
right the thing is though they they were
both they're both fine oh yeah they're
both fine uh the taller skinnier one
like the beup chick what was her name
again uh Tisa was her character's name
Tisa she's just a different popular body
style of that era which is kind of just
taller an aqualine she got real nice
legs and stuff you know and I kind of
liked her better cuz she was like
snarkier yeah yeah the other was a
little shorter and a little little bit
more voluptuous but they still
were like uh I wouldn't say they're not
like fashion models more like pinup
girls kind of like like Penthouse Pets
they were about like that yeah um which
I liked those better all right I think a
lot of dud guys were more into like
Penthouse Pet type stuff than [__]
models um but no they got it right um
and what I really liked about the movie
is that the female characters were good
they were good they they were smart they
uh [__] were heroic and they won in
the end and uh they were
like it was male fantasy [__] it was
like you know they had these teenage
guys going man I wish my girlfriend wish
I had a girlfriend that was that hot and
that badass that's what they're doing
yeah and you know cuz the interesting
thing and we were talking about this
when we were watching the movie cuz this
is how this is how we roll yeah but
because we had watched the trailer yeah
beforehand cuz it just comes on
automatically on Amazon and the way they
made the movie look in the trailer was
this is going to be non-stop hot chicks
getting sexually assaulted pretty much
yeah and they can't do anything about
and being chained up yeah yeah so it's
like that happens in literally the first
minute or two of the movie but they
immediately Escape steal a spaceship and
get the [__] off that planet and then
they go to this other planet and yeah
they get hunted but it's like that from
the minute they get there they are const
L like figuring out like how we going to
get out of here how we going to like get
so I like that they kind of I don't know
if I want to call it a bait and switch
but they were kind of likein going to
like teenage boys it's like hey see hot
chicks get raped but it's just kind of
like the movie is not there is one rape
scene in it but it does nothing happens
in it really not not really like it
doesn't last very long yeah and um you
know and and then she gets rescued it
geted yeah the other girl stayes there
now there is an implied rape they don't
show it yeah uh and this is with Brink
Steven uh Brink Stevens is her name
right yeah she's like a very famous
scream Queen I recognized her from
sorority babes in the slime ball bolama
but she was in like a bunch of other
stuff as well yeah she's a real hot
brunette yeah yeah yeah so she's in this
too she's on the planet already like
when they get there like her and her
brother are there even she dies a heroic
death she get she [__] gives her life
to save like sacrifices herself like to
save the other one so the other ones can
get away so it's just like I really kind
of like that they did that I like that
they kind of like sold it as like an
like an exploitation flick it's like hey
just see these women get [__] up but
then like when you see the actual movie
yeah you get to see their boobies and
everything like that and there are
scenes like that but the women are very
proactive I remember being that age
though and falling for that right for
that kind of tactic and what it is is
it's it's pulling it's pulling on the
sympathy strings yeah you're seeing this
beautiful chicks they're showing them
scandy clad something bad happened to
them well you got to see this man cuz
you might be able to [__] help out
what I'm talking about we got to stop
this that's what it is that's what no I
have to save you yeah yeah we're going
to save them you know there you go and
that wasn't what it all they saved they
save their own theyve their own yeah
yeah but that's you guys can back me up
on that they know how to fly spaceships
they know how to shoot laser guns they
know how to beat robots up yeah they
know how to trick robots they can do all
that [__] yeah what they are is they're
basically female the female equivalent
of cute little Conan chicks in a that
can fly spaceships and shoot Ray Guns
it's like something out of out of heavy
metal magazine which kind of makes sense
in the context of the universe of the
movie because I mean it's implied that
when they got taken from their planet or
you know kidna by the robots or whatever
that it's like they lived on a planet
they're just running around a Lo cloth
and bare feet so it's like they were
tough they lived on this plan they had
to they could instantly fly a spaceship
I don't know how that happens but they
knew exactly and they could even run the
navigational computers and [__] remember
yeah they knew and we were kind of like
well when that happened cuz that happens
like in the first couple minutes of the
movie Shoot they can fly this and I was
just like awesome yeah they were just
like [__] this we're out of here and
it's like hey I know how to fly one of
these blah blah blah and they like they
knew the names of other planets yeah
they knew where everything was and [__]
like that yeah iess they weren't that
primitive yeah so that was like well I
guess in the universe of this there was
a lot of that going on in the 80s I feel
like there was this kind of combination
of kind of primitive stuff with like I
said that's why there was that whole
sword and sorcery thing where it was
just kind of like kind of sci-fi but
also you know caveman like SFI caveman
kind of [__] going on there was a lot of
that kind of crossover but yeah I mean I
don't know I did kind of like that about
the whole thing that they knew what they
were doing I wanted to like there's a
character in this though and I can't
maybe I'm thinking about this more than
obviously I'm thinking about this more
than the people that made the movie did
but there's a character in this who I
wasn't sure if he was a robot or a
mutant or whatever but it's like
whenever he turned up I'm was like hey
it's you know beef cake the mighty like
you know what I mean like he's like the
Lost member of gu or whatever because he
kind of looked like one of the members
of gu from back in the day and I
couldn't figure out what his deal was
because the bad guy the hunter guy on
the planet he had some robots that were
guards but then there was this other
situation going on with this dude who
was kind of like a robot but then also
kind of like a monster like I said who
kind of looked like he was in gu oh no
not talking about no and okay so what
was the deal with that because he seemed
to be kind of helping them but then they
were kind of like ah [__] that guy and
they like killed him anyway yeah that
was what that was is that was a ripoff
Predator right he was like a but why was
he helping them though I don't think he
was I think he just kind of was kind of
shot in a bad way they were just leaving
it I think he was attacking them I think
or maybe he was helping him and they
they murdered him and they were just
like ah [__] that he's probably a bad
guy look at him for Christ's sake CU I
couldn't figure that out because it's
like he seemed to be like taking out the
robots and then they're like ah [__] him
and they shot him anyway I like wow
harsh I think it was because you know
that Predator was probably out by the so
on the game planet was also an alien
Predator this was the same year that
Predator came out I think this came out
the same year I maybe scuttlebutt got
out maybe because he's like a reptile
his Jaws go sideways and he's got
high-tech weapons on
him I think it was a ripoff Predator I
just couldn't figure it out because
there's this whole scene at the
beginning where there's like a fight and
then I don't think they knew uh probably
not I said well that's what I said while
you were gone I said I'm probably
thinking about this more than like
anybody the made this movie did they're
just kind of like hey
man this was a full moon uh
entertainment yeah release and that was
kind of their whole thing was like doing
exploitation movie another thing is that
there may have been other scenes deleted
that's true and they may have changed it
he maybe he was going to be helping them
at first but then they decided they
didn't want to go that route they're
like yeah so cuz they much they blew his
ass up yeah I was just wondering about
it now here cool weapons yeah shooting
[__] one of the ones at the end I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure it was a
leaf blower M pretty sure this one she
got this Sonic gun that she took from
the alien I
think didn't she get that off the
Predator alien she knew all about it
well they found that Temple and then
there was that big like coffin looking
thing and it had all the weapons which
is right right out of Aliens versus
Predator yeah so she got the [__]
maybe ripped that off so then uh she
gets this uh Lea blower weapon that shot
I me the end of it looks like a leaf
yeah shot some kind of Sonic Ray and she
she reasons along with her friend there
TAA well [__] if I go 360° the [__]
The Echoes and everything from the Sonic
weapon will bounce back and I'll find
out the the exit so she just does it
180° though and she goes well they're
back to back so I guess I guess that
kind of counts no because she never
[__] came around and got that other
got that got her side well see I thought
the implication was that the weapon that
Tissa had was also a Sonic weapon so
they were covering 300 I guess I don't
know they didn't make that super clear
yeah they were two different weapons you
know what I mean and then she goes it's
that way and I was like okay I like at
one point too like they actually set
traps for the oily dude that was hunting
them yeah yeah Zed his name was and um I
thought cuz this this would have been
awesome if they' done this I thought
that she cuz she made this like spiky
thing and he ran right into it like a
dumbass and I thought it went like right
into his dick and i' been like awesome
but no it was just his thigh I was like
no I was kind of disappointed but oh
well also here's a funny funny uh fun
fact about this movie this movie has
actually been mentioned on uh the floors
of the Senate because back in 19 1992
good old Jesse Helms if you remember
that old fart I remember that guy yeah I
remember the name um he mentioned this
movie specifically he was trying to they
were trying to do something they trying
to um they were trying to do like the
cable Act of 1992 where they were trying
to because they're like oh my God this
child was scrolling through cable one
night and came across this movie and
were traumatized for life and so cable
channels should block these kind of
movies like they can't show them anymore
and stuff like that like it didn't pass
but he was trying to get this movie well
he just wanted to talk about this one
because it has a sensational title yeah
this movie's tame is sh it is very tame
I mean seriously yeah there's titties um
there's a couple titty shots there's sex
scenes but they're like you don't really
see anything other than boobs there's a
rape scene but you don't hardly see
anything there's another rape scene but
it's implied like they don't even show
anything like you show they show Brink
Stevens like like um bound to a table
like from this side and she's naked and
stuff and they imply that that guy raped
her but they don't show it show it they
do show him like kind of raping her
toward the end but like it but he gets
interrupted it's not even predat tration
it's just kind of Pawn on her yeah he's
just kind of like she he puts her like
over a table like yeah but then it's
nothing it's nothing like [__] Last
House on the Left or I Spit on Your
Grave or anything like that Jesus Christ
not even it's not even remotely close
not even like death wish one not even
close that's what I mean it's it was it
it's very theatrical or [__] like
honestly one of the worst rape scenes
I've ever other than I Spit on Your
Grave which I can't hardly watch like
the one from the 70s um was that French
film
irreversible God I had a hard time
sitting through that [__] [__] CU it
went on a long time well the one and Ice
spit on your grave does too I have a
hard time watching that [__] in movies
but yeah so it's just kind of like this
was like nothing compared to that so
it's just like really funny that it just
kind of shows how [__] sensitive
those [__] were back in the 80s this
is so [__] T Jessie Helms probably
didn't see this I don't heard how would
he just see this and let although I kind
of feel like those kind of like those
old dudes that are like super like
upright like that they're like the
biggest [__] freaks man they're
probably they're probably watching all
kind of like [__] like oh yeah oh hell
yeah and like jerking into yeah and
somebody one of his staff just put this
title down right in the [__] speech
they those dudes are fake they're fake
today and they were fake back then
they're they're actors basically I mean
the more you go on about how morally
upright you are oh yeah you're dang the
the worse you are yes the the more [__]
you have to hide Yeah Yeah the more
you're trying to cover CU if you don't
have anything to hide then you'll just
kind of Let It All Hang Out won't well
it's a technique that they're using it's
not for them it's for the audience and
they're just trying to trying to get I'm
just surprised anybody Falls for it so
listen to them but like yeah like all of
them it's just funny that like back in
the early 90s he was at he trying to get
a [__] law pass that cable could cuz
some innocent child somewhere might see
a
tit good Lord oh my God it's not like
half the [__] world's population
doesn't have them for CH sake well
actually like technically men have tits
too so you know the thing is though the
movie wasn't about that that didn't even
really stand out not really no I mean
yeah there's tits in it little flashes
of them but really what you're mostly
seeing is uh [__] girls in bikinis
running around yeah nice legs yeah nice
booties yeah there's not like a lck of
like nudity nudity yeah you see some
tits like every now and then but yeah
mostly they're just walking around in
like skimpy outfits Sky outfits and
cavage like running around in just
skimpy outfits yeah like with their
boots kind exctly what a teenage boy
want to see right they [__] did a
good job and back in the day when you
couldn't get free porn everywhere Yep
this is this was the best thing that you
had this is what you would have seen
[__] late night on Cinemax or HBO you
stayed up all night to see this [__]
you're [__] 15 for not even not even
15 like 13 you're 13 you're standing up
to see this [__] I mean you oh yeah hell
yeah that was great man [__] you tell
your buddy did you see that yeah we saw
it all three of you sitting there
drinking right out of the two ler of pop
and
[__] [__] you potato chips and [__] damn
look at her look look look look look
you're [__] 13 yeah yeah yeah hell
yeah I know yeah like I said it's y guys
you you guys know in a way it's like
teenagers nowadays it's like it's so
easy like you can just see whatever the
[__] whatever freaky [__] you want to
see it's like just it's a click away
back then I don't think they even care
about it anymore well because it's
everywhere it's ubiquitous like back
then you could it was harder to get yeah
so it's like ooh like it felt like a lot
more illicit it's a very narrow band
Universe we lived in had a few channels
like back then you know it's like
nowadays people are just kind of like
hey I want to see a woman [__] a goat
oh oh okay there we there we go there it
is it's there's multiple you know what I
mean it's just like so nothing is
shocking anymore really which I don't
know I kind of like it's kind of sad in
a way well kind of like that though well
we were in a we were in a universe of
mystery though things true I do I well
that there is some Allure to that I I
get it yeah um but I think in a way I
think it's kind of healthier like for
people's psyches just for everything to
just be hanging out there maybe maybe
not to an extent I mean you know up to
on your I up to a certain point up to a
certain point also I think your
intelligence has a lot to do with it but
yeah so it's just like this movie is
just so it's just funny that it caused
such a brewhaha back in in the [__]
late ' 80s and early '90s cuz there's
like literally nothing to it it's just
kind of like like I said I've seen way
way worse [__] actually I've seen way
worse [__] that came out in the 70s yeah
like and this was like late 80s like
some of the movies I saw in the 70s were
way more [__] up than this yeah this
was a good-spirited movie yeah yeah it's
just fun it's kind of cute and fun it's
like you know they're just playing off
the Conan sure and and and star crash
remember the movie star crash like Star
crash and con that's got your girl in it
Caroline Mon oh [__] yeah and then
star crash and everybody loves Carolina
all that [__] there were Star Wars
ripoffs but they just use a tired old
story most dangerous game because easy
to
do and uh came out in the 20s you don't
got to pay anybody any LIC worry about
copyright and uh most teenagers of that
era probably wouldn't know this most
dangerous game yeah they wouldn't know
like that it was based on this that was
a great story boy they [__] I read that
story in like Junior High I think I
think it came out in the 20s 1924 I
think that story came out yeah but I
remember you know we read it like in
school but they have made like a zillion
movie adaptations of it and most of them
aren't called the most dangerous game
because they're trying to like get one
over I guess like I said you get this
generic story gen generic story that
they could tell that was copyright free
yeah they renamed it a sensational name
to sell it that way to teenage
guys well and and it worked on me too
because I'm sitting there going slave
girls from beyond Infinity we have to
watch that you got to see that
one they weren't slaves they were
captives they weren't slaves yeah that
yeah it's like I said it's a little bit
of a misn they're misnaming things yeah
they captives and they got away and like
I said they were really only in chains
for like a minute yeah and because Daria
immediately she's like chained to the
floor and she's like [__] this papow she
just like gets out and the other chick's
like wow awesome like and they just like
[__] got out and then they sto of
spaceship yeah and then it goes to the
other planet yeah so and you know I I
don't know I I just thought that was
like pretty cool I thought it was pretty
cool the whole even though like you said
it was kind of a bait and switch Yeah
but in the in the best possible way now
a troma film or a [__] yeah or what's
the other one [__] Asylum it would
have been that although I kind of feel
like Asylum are kind of more known for
well I guess this is kind of a ripoff
because it's a ripoff of a short Story
asylum are more known for it's like
what's the big Blockbuster right now
let's make something like that with a
title that's almost exactly the same
yeah we're going to redo
Transformers like that and they call it
like transmorphers or something and then
like yeah like Pacific Rim comes out
let's make Atlantic Rim you know what I
mean yeah which they did that was on
that was on Rift tracks actually an
Antarctic
Rim I mean it works yeah you can't [__]
on them too hard and then they know that
you know that you're watching a ripoff
they'll they'll [__] bag on the fact
that you're watching a ripoff [__]
those are good flicks man and they
always get like they always get these
actors that were like real big on like
[__] shows in the 90s and stuff and
they're like kind of past their Prime
yeah but then they'll have some
unabashedly hot chicks in there well
yeah like jiggling boobies so it's kind
of the equivalent I'm saying it's kind
of the equivalent we she there to be hot
that's it right we still have the thing
yeah it's like oh yeah she's a physicist
and she's like w with these big titties
like yeah [__] double
G physicist with double G implants no
saying there aren't some physicists out
there that have double G titties I'm
sure there I'm sure there's a few yeah
she's got a gun and
everything and she's also and she's also
a ninja yeah beautiful ass hair she's
also a ninja that's right it's
great like I said if you're going to go
that route just pile it on that's right
make it as ridiculous as possible it's a
lot more fun for everyone involved the
worst thing you can make is a boring
movie yeah just if you can't make it
good just at least don't make it boring
just make it as [__] ridiculous one
of one of my favorite movies was made by
Asylum and it's a masterpiece [__]
Nazis from the center of the earth
that's a great [__] movie it is so
fun and it is accurate it's so fun it's
historically
accurate well and we've gone on at Great
length about one of our favorite bad
movies which is
veloor which was not made by Asylum good
but they just had a great [__]
concept they had like no money but yeah
they leaned into it but they were also
like real genuine yeah and like made it
real earnestly and I think that made it
work even better because that was oh my
God it's talking too much oh me I'm
talking too much oh my God go [__]
yourself
Tom he tells me I'm talking too
much and he's already been PE like to
like this is like the second or third
time he's always going to the bathroom
Ben says slave chains from wish yeah
clearly they were because it's like well
the whole setup was the other chick
Tissa I guess she'd been I don't think
they specified like how long she had
been there but she's just like oh I
already tried to get out it's useless or
whatever and like this other chick shows
up and she's like [__] that and she's
like PW and she gets out like
immediately and she's like oh I guess my
upper body strength isn't what I thought
it was you know what I mean so then they
both get out but yeah so they're
definitely definitely not the greatest
because I'm pretty sure you couldn't
just pull the [__] chain apart like
that unless they were from wish maybe
they were plastic I don't know um
Tammy says a girl has to keep all that
knowledge somewhere sometimes it slips
down to the
titties well that was kind of one of the
because we were I mean we were actually
really enjoying this movie but you know
I I've been an MST fan for so long that
I can't help but like reflectively like
make jokes about movies like even good
ones like while I'm watching them so
which makes me a really annoying person
to watch movies with I'm just saying no
but I like this movie out of these two
movies I would give it I would give my
ratings to this one I think it's five
five stars in its in its type in its
genre which is be
movie I take slave girls and it knows
what it is yeah yeah and it had like
some it actually had some lines in it
that genuinely like made me laugh you
were laughing yeah yeah and not like in
a ww kind of way but I'm just like oh my
God that was genuinely funny now we saw
one after this that was uh better maybe
we'll talk about that one later but I
haven't finished it cuz I fell I fell
asleep we got a few more minutes we got
to finish it that one was called the
Phantom Empire the Phantom Empire jeffre
comes in it and Jeffree comes was in it
and I [__] love Jeffrey comes we had
a whole Jeffrey combes Marathon over the
weekend because like I said if you
weren't here at the beginning we
actually rewatched all the reanimator
movies over the weekend just cuz cuz and
um every time if every time like we're
watching all the reanimator movies I'm
like God I [__] love Jeffrey com man
he's like his facial expressions Phantom
Empire's um a different kind of
movie we might review it later it's
better than than than slave girls from
the edge of infinity is that it's called
edge of infinity no from beyond infinity
beyond beyond Infinity I don't even know
that's far away y' I don't even know
Phantom Empire is more kind of like one
of those uh uh [__] uh forian movies
like [__] at Earth's core yeah it
kind of reminded me of something like
that one those British flicks where like
we're going in this cave and there's all
these like trite type yeah the people
that time creatures yeah it's kind of
it's kind of more like that that kind of
stuff kind more like they go into a cave
and come out
still they come out in the inner earth
where there's a sky and a [__] sun
and how kind kind of like the mole
people see like the mole people is kind
of like that also and they got a hot ass
alien chick with big old boobs who's
molesting Jeffrey coms and F jeffre okay
Jeff's like well if you say so she got
these big old cans and [__] [__]
blonde hair he's like hey it's part of
her culture I'm not going to I'm not
going yeah Robbie the robot was in it
they just Robbie the robot yeah that was
totally Robbie the robot yeah it changed
its head so it looked different but that
was Robbie the robot they had to fight
that there's um trite people in the cave
that are cannibals there's uh [__]
Savage girls that [__] wear [__]
Rawhide bikinis just like in this movie
they're in there U maybe that's why they
recommended this one next they like hey
you like Rawhide bikinis some more yeah
so it's kind of like that it's kind like
those old British movies but it's
American yeah it's funny though this
[__] got Hil they obviously they had
the Char the actors themselves are
writing some of the dialogue yeah cuz
some of the lines in this were super
funny like genuinely like they didn't
have a writer that writing that [__]
that was the actors [__] doing that
[__] was [__] funny they also seemed
like their because they were telling
them to just add lib a lot of
[__] they were back you know this had to
have been Ben says the smarter a woman
is the bigger her DRS will be M yeah and
the sexier her little glasses will be
little glasses sexy little
glasses yeah well well Tammy argues that
the knowledge has to go somewhere and
sometimes it goes into the titties yeah
that's where all my knowledge is right
in here yeah it's
fuckid do a tit trap J if I ever need to
if I ever need some information I just
need to pull just pull it out like like
a Kleenex coming out of the box is that
weird I don't know tamy said uh pissing
a lot might want to get that prostate
checked LOL I heard getting pegs can
help
man a Tom yeah you piss they piss a lot
but not much comes out man my [__]
[__] comes
out e okay I drink a lot all day not
yeah he does yeah I'm drinking a lot man
just right before the show we went to
[__] Dollar General and he got like a
whole bunch of soda sodas and [__] yeah
I don't really drink soda I don't like
[__] love soda but he'll just like
[__] drink all of it see you just
drink all that cuz I don't drink
any like soda and milk I'll drink milk
with ice in it too used to drink milk a
lot but I don't really I kind of lost
the taste for it I used to drink it a
lot when I was growing up got to make my
protein requirements yeah I guess so uh
Ben said have you seen Dr reanimator
dance hit move those bones I have not uh
Joseph says I like the Jeffrey comes
episode of Masters of Horror he played
Edgar Allen Poe yeah yeah yeah that's
right he went on tour for that he did
yeah
um man we were kind of talking about it
last night it's like can we find him is
he on tour and he probably wouldn't be
coming to Florida because they got to go
down come back yeah a lot of people
don't come to Florida I can't really say
I blame him but yeah it's I would like
to see him like yeah do like the live
[__] or I would like to like meet him at
a convention or something he seems like
a cool dude I really I like Jeffrey want
to have him on the show as a guest yeah
he seems like keep be fun we can all we
could all get drunk with Jeffrey comes
yeah he drinks on on podcast and that's
yeah so do we so we have something in
common like's great guest he's a great
guest I don't know if he'll come on a
show this small probably not but uh yeah
he's a great guest but just rewatching
all the reanimator movies um over the
weekend I was just kind of like man he's
like so underappreciated I feel like I
[__] love Jeffrey comes he's like
[__] he cracks me up and all those
movies are good all those movies are
good they didn't make the they just made
the three right as far as I know yeah
yeah reanimator bride of reanimator and
Beyond reanimator yeah the last one that
was no Brian from Beyond is a very
similar to yeah we watched from Beyond
too
yeah that is really good but he's not in
it trying to think what else he's in uh
Necronomicon he's in that he he plays he
he plays HP glove craft he play H they
got [__] they they Chang it's an
anthology it's good I liked it I wanted
to see it again it's from the 90s I
think it's from 94 I want to say yeah
that must be in some kind of legal limbo
because I think it has we couldn't find
it anywhere I don't think you can find
DVDs or Blu-Rays of
it really weird it seemed to have like
fallen through the cracks yeah we
reviewed it like a few years ago I don't
know what's happened to it since I saw
it on on YouTube for free yeah we looked
last night but I didn't find I mean I'll
look again tomorrow to see but I don't I
couldn't find it last night I looked
couldn't find it free and you couldn't
find it to
rent yeah was kind of a bummer cuz I
remember kind of liking that but yeah
all right so it's almost 9 o' so you
want to wrap it up yep all righty so
we're going to wrap it up for the
evening hope you guys enjoyed the double
feature um for Wednesday's show we're
actually going back to the True Crime we
are going to talk about a Korean serial
killer Yu young chw uh also known as the
raincoat killer all right so we're going
to talk about him uh so that should be
fun that's what won in the poll and we
haven't done true crime in a while so
that should be pretty fun so hopefully
you guys can make it for that so have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow and we'll see you again on
Wednesday day night good night